[Musica]
ora si sente o la buona stare sono
davvero emozionata sono grata e sono
onorata di essere qui al the dance e di
incontrarvi non a caso questo
quest'estate da ex a proprio come non
man come il tema i contri e quindi un
meraviglioso incontro già muove lani che
mi ha invitata a qui e che ringrazio
pubblicamente mi ha chiesto di
rispondere ad una domanda
quella che vedete sullo schermo come
affrontare al meglio gli incontri che la
vita riserva ed io da coach e quindi da
allenatrice mentale non potevo fare
altro che accettare perché perché le
domande sono sicuramente uno dei
migliori strumenti che si possono
utilizzare nella vita in quanto fanno
partire proprio dei processi mentali e
quindi come affrontare al meglio gli
incontri che la vita ci offre
allora la vita è una serie di incontri è
quello che dobbiamo fare la prima corda
per affrontarle al meglio è
riconosci
voglio fare un esempio quest'oggi voi
tutti siete qui al the dance e quindi
siete ad un incontro l'incontro con
degli speaker che sono qui sul palco ma
anche l'incontro con le persone che sono
presenti qui a questo incontro
io vi inviterei a guardarvi un attimo
intorno provò a 360 gradi
voglio vedervi fatemi vedere
riguardate un attimo intorno riguardate
un attimo sembrare o vedete qui ci sono
persone che hanno un comune o più comuni
denominatori con voi
ovvero sono persone curiose sono persone
avverte all'ascolto all'osservazione
persone che vogliono prendere
consapevolezza e quest'oggi fino ad
adesso ne abbiamo prese tante tante di
consapevolezze sono persone che si
vogliono mettere in gioco e quindi
persone che hanno degli interessi comuni
la mia domanda è ma vi siete presentati
con la persona che avete al fianco con
la persona che avete dietro quella
persona che avete davanti
è una parola molto bella che noi diciamo
quando ci presentiamo che piacere
piacere vero piacere
quale miglior piacere di incontrare
persone che hanno già i nostri stessi
interessi e quindi quando andiamo fuori
poterla incontrare guardarle negli occhi
e dire per il ted kennedy che può essere
una buona idea
magari presentarsi e cogliere in questo
tipo di opportunità
adesso che ve ne pare se vi do 20
secondi per farlo alza un pochino le
luci così vediamo come si presentano
presentate li avete 20 secondi conto
fino 20 mentalmente per farlo guardatemi
degli occhi e fatelo in modo cosciente
ah che bello meraviglioso bene bene bene
bene bene perfetto e quindi e qui b e
quindi che cosa che cosa abbiamo
imparato fino adesso cosa abbiamo
imparato che il primo passo il primo
passo per affrontare al meglio gli
incontri che la vita ci riserva è quello
di occuparci di riconoscere l'ambiente
nel quale siamo di vivere nel qui ed ora
praticamente di occuparci e vivere il
presente
che ne pensate può essere un po un modo
di cogliere le opportunità e di
affrontare al meglio gli incontri che la
vita ci riserva
eh sì perché la vita come vi abbia detto
precedentemente i fatali incontro nella
mia vita non fatti veramente tanti
incontri con paesi diversi paesi e
incontri con culture con luoghi con
persone con lingue diverse e ogni volta
questa cosa insomma di incontrarli mi ha
insegnato l'importanza di appunto vivere
il presente e di essere lì e rendermi
conto delle risorse che avevo intorno a
me e delle risorse che potevano essere
essere già a mia disposizione venete di
una bimba da bimbi io sono nata a
caracas la mia storia inizia da lì in
sudamerica venezuela e quello che ho
imparato stando lì con quella cultura è
questo ok ovvero avere un atteggiamento
costruttivo e quindi pensare sempre io
sono ok ma anche tu sei ok ok e non solo
diciamo che ho avuto un un'educazione
alquanto disciplinata che mi ha permesso
di prepararmi e quindi di occuparmi di
impegnarmi tanto di allenarmi
infatti ho fatto diverse cose antica
danza chitarra chi più ne ha più ne
metta
e questo mi ha permesso di capire che
un'altra cosa che fa in modo che noi
possiamo affrontare al meglio le le cose
le situazioni e gli eventi di incontri
tra la vita ci riserva è quella di
abilitare di allenare allenare la mente
allenare corpo allenare lo spirito e che
significa sviluppare i propri talenti e
questa cosa mi è servita tantissimo
sapete quando quando per esempio sono
arrivata in
in toscana che cosa è accaduto io ho
vissuto
diciamo la mia pre adolescenza quando
sono arrivata in italia per un anno in
campania e siccome non sapevo l'italiano
ho imparato il dialetto perché all'epoca
soprattutto insomma si parlava in
dialetto e quando sono arrivata in
toscana parlava un mix tra dialetto
campano e spagnolo una cosa abbastanza
diciamo la verità non molto
comprensibile e ho avuto un incontro
abbastanza doloroso con la scuola in
particolare con un insegnante un
insegnante che ogni volta che entravo a
scuola mi metteva proprio in fondo
all'aula perché ero diversa per il fatto
di appunto di parlare cosi e che mi
ripeteva continuamente continuamente una
frase parla italiano
altrimenti il ghiaccio con uno
scarafaggio facevo proprio così e nella
mente di una adolescente insomma essere
vista come uno scarafaggio non è proprio
il massimo delle immagini meno male che
grazie alla mia educazione al fatto cioè
di vedere sempre il meglio nelle cose e
al fatto di essere abituata ad allenarmi
e quindi a sviluppare i talenti che
avevo dentro di me ho iniziato ad usare
un'altra cosa
il potere dell'immaginazione
ed è proprio questo l'invito che io mi
faccio quest'oggi usare il potere della
vostra immaginazione oltre che
l'allenamento
ovviamente alla preparazione e le varie
abilità
e grazie a questo potere io ho iniziato
ad immaginare come una persona sempre
con un microfono in mano a tornare
italiano di fronte ad un pubblico
italiano ed ho iniziato a fare molta
esperienza in merito
oltre a studiare la grammatica oltre a
leggere una quantità infinita di libri
oltre a fare corsi di dizione
quindi lo studio ho iniziato a
trasmettere in radio per esempio quindi
mettermi gioco 17 anni poi ho iniziato a
cantare e fare la vocalist fare
presentazioni
insomma alla fine grazie alla mia
immaginazione a vedermi così sempre
tutti i giorni e abilitarmi anche oggi
come vedete un microfono e sono davanti
ad un pubblico italiano quindi usare
l'immaginazione visualizzati già avanti
oltre e questo è molto importante
è importante perché se cambi tu abbia il
mondo intorno a te e l'unico modo per
vivere al meglio il proprio futuro è
proprio quello di crearlo dentro di te
quindi il miglior modo di infettare il
tuo futuro nel presente e crearlo dentro
di te e tutti gli incontri tutti tutti
gli incontri di noi potremmo fare la
nostra vita sono dei maestri
dei grandissimi maestri questa sera ad
arezzo
cosa c'è in coro cosa c'è stasera ad
arezzo il saracino è generalmente c'è un
personaggio proprio che protagonista
sempre no del saracino vedete quale è il
buratto e il buratto allora di ma di
dimostrare al mondo che tutti proprio
tutti siamo esseri speciali pieni di
risorse infinite dentro di noi e che
quindi possiamo allenare la nostra mente
per congruenza il nostro corpo e anche
il nostro spirito ovviamente e quindi
possiamo dimostrare al mondo che abbiamo
dei superpoteri ci state a fare un
esercizio con me c'è stata o no ti sento
un po quando c'è da mettersi in gioco
allora abbiamo un attimino di luci in
sala pochino pochino
allora perché le faccio da fare per
vederci innanzitutto per vedervi per voi
e mi vorrei far provare venire qua no è
bellissimo perché io parlo ma parlo
praticamente al buio e non vedo nulla e
nulla più totale adesso riesco a un
attimino vedere le vostre le vostre
facce allora io adesso userò questo a
trentino vivi però ad altra rebellin in
piedi che nicchia di asti ok bene e
andremo a dimostrare che anche noi siamo
dei supereroi abbiamo adesso per poteri
ok allora io mi farò vedere qual è la
cosa che va fatta
questo momento questa the fermino la
fatemi guardate poi lo fate anche voi
vedete io mi metto con i piedi
le spalle metto un braccio di fronte a
me così fosse e poi faccio una rotazione
di questo tipo dando proprio il massimo
del livello di rotazione ok
dovete rendere proprio male cioè dare
proprio il massimo che più di un uccello
ci siamo senza muovere i piedi di fermi
per di fermi fermi proviamo andiamo
siete pronti pronti via
aveva in più e mi devi far male male
male male male male male male male male
ebbe torniamo in posizione adesso
useremo la nostra immaginazione
quindi vi chiederò di fare un gioco con
meglio chiudere gli occhi di stare fermi
quindi non muovermi e di far lavorare
solamente la vostra mente quindi io mi
dirò cosa fare
da voi lo farete lamenta all'interno
della vostra mente non con il vostro
corpo detto ok ci state
andiamo con l'esperimento molto bene
allora chiudiamo gli occhi adesso dovete
immaginare di essere tipo lardo si il
buratto sapete che pur atto gira gira e
gira intorno a sé stante in tante tante
volte è possibile e quindi andiamo a
girare pronti e 2 e 3 girate tirata
immaginatelo e 56 bene torniamo che il
flessibilità che l'artista che potenza
bello noi facciamo un'altra volta
sempre con la nostra immaginazione
pronti via ed elastici visibili potete
fare qualsiasi pola bene e abbiamo gli
occhi e adesso li fate l'esercizio di
prima e fatelo a modesta viene via via
si è tentato un pochino quella di quatto
ditemi un po pensa così di quanto
pensano si è prima avevate dato il
massimo
come vedete grazie alla nostra
immaginazione è possibile andare oltre
oltre quelli che sono i nostri limiti e
se noi ci alleniamo e ci alleniamo tutti
i giorni nelle cose che vogliamo
possiamo andare oltre a quello che la
fantasia ci può dare
c'è un grandissimo oggi che io apprezzo
tanto li considero come il mio numero
uno che claudio melotti che dice poi non
avete sufficiente fantasia per
immaginare dove potete arrivare e quindi
vi esorto a utilizzare sempre la vostra
immaginazione unità ovviamente
all'allenamento all'impegno alla
preparazione alla determinazione quindi
abilitarci e crederci vivere così
in quel modo lì impotenza credendo in
noi e per noi perché quando noi abbiamo
un livello di energia alto riusciamo a
dare tante energie anche agli altri ma
se noi abbiamo un livello di energia
l'occhio cosa possiamo dare al mondo
cosa possiamo dare agli altri
ben poco sicuramente un livello e dei
risultati che non sono i risultati che
invece potremmo sicuramente avere e
quindi oltre a questi strumenti
cosa si può fare e come possiamo
affrontare al meglio gli incontri della
nostra vita con altri due strumenti uno
in questo lo conoscete
fatevi vedere che lo conoscete fate
vedere e l'altro è un dio dove era un
bel cuore gigante va beh meno male che
l'evento stato nell'altro è questo
ok un cuore che avete dentro quello che
pulsa che vi permette di vivere quando
quello smette di battere
non ci siamo più quindi mettiamo una
mano sul cuore e sorridiamo e quindi
sorridiamo con la mano sul cuore a noi
stessi prima di tutto dicendo grazie
si è grazie all universo che c'è intorno
a noi
ricordatevi che la parola coraggio
contiene al suo interno la parola cuore
e quindi viviamo e potenza con il
sorriso e con coraggio
grazie infinite
[Applauso]
[Musica]